Speaker 1: Well, my friends, I hate to
have to do this to you again, I really do,
I wish that things were different
than they are. But unfortunately,
what we talked about at the start of this week,
as far as the virus is concerned, the pandemic,
it seems to be coming true and we're going to go
through the data. And again, I want this to be
over as much as everyone. And I have, like many
of us, started to go back to just a more normal
pre-pandemic way of living. And all of it, I'm
with everybody on this stuff, but we have to talk
about things as they are and not as we wish that
they would be in. Earlier this week, I told you
we're starting to see a little bit of an uptick in
some European countries, in some Asian countries,
and in all likelihood, at some point this
is going to come here to the United States,
and then we're going to have to figure out how bad
is this going to get and how deadly is this going
to be? And all of the questions we've all been
exhaustingly grappling with now for two years,
plus a week where basically two years plus a week,
I guess you'd call it a hundred and five weeks
into this pandemic in some way, shape or
form. And there are some very ugly numbers
from yesterday. We'll put these up on the screen
for people who are watching today in South Korea,
going all the way back to the start of the
pandemic. More cases than ever in one day
yesterday. Not in 2020. Not in 2021. The worst
day for new cases in South Korea was yesterday,
with about 400 thousand new cases. That is an
ugly chart. Imagine a really steep mountain
so steep that you'd fall off of it if you tried
to climb it. That's what the cases look like in
South Korea. If you're listening today in Germany,
a very big spike to the point where Germany now
on an average seven day average is at the highest
point of the pandemic, now averaging about 210
thousand cases a day. South Korea and Germany
very different countries, but we are seeing the
same thing happen in Vietnam, just an unbelievable
spike now regularly logging one hundred and 75000
new COVID cases per day. Ugly, ugly, ugly.
It makes the first year and a half of the
pandemic look like there were no cases in Vietnam
because of how high the numbers are now. France
Although France had a disastrous R Macron
wave, so the numbers are nowhere near that yet.
But. Other than the immigrant Spike, France
is also experiencing average daily cases now
higher than the first, second and third spikes in
the U.K., which has been a big leading indicator.
I don't know that there's any country that
has better predicted what happens in the U.S.
than the U.K. throughout the pandemic. The UK's
daily case numbers are now back up to about
67000 cases per day, and there's a question as
to whether that's as high as it's going to go or
whether it's going to continue climbing. Italy,
which remember at the very beginning. Italy had
one of the worst spikes that spike when we now
look back. Looks like nothing. It looks. It looks
almost completely flat in April of 2020, and that
was outdone in November of 2020, and of course,
overwhelmingly outdone by the Macron spike.
Italy is now higher than at any point other than
the R Macron spike. These are really, really ugly
numbers. Now let's kind of talk through what's the
most disastrous interpretation? Well, some of that
we're seeing in a number of different articles.
One such article in stat news with infections
spiking in Europe and a variant on the rise.
Experts warn the U.S. could face a COVID
resurgence and of course, we don't know how bad
it could get. We're still seeing a thousand people
a day die. So could that get back up to 2000 3000?
It's a question mark, and obviously the
hope is no. The hope would be no. Now
some of you might be saying, wait,
and I haven't heard of a new variant.
This is kind of a sub variant of Macron are Macron
was called the a one variant. We're now seeing
B a two. It's not its own unique variant. In a
sense, it's part of the same R Macron lineage. And
from what we know right now, and I always want
to be careful from what we know as of right now,
it is equivalent to R Macron in terms of
severity, but it seems to be more contagious.
So it's not its own variant, but it is a version
of al-Muqrin. So that that's kind of that's that's
a pessimistic or more alarmist reaction. NBC
News reporting on what the W.H.O. now says.
W.H.O. says global rise in COVID cases is only
the tip of the iceberg after more than a month of
decline. Global COVID cases rose last week, with
the biggest jump in the western Pacific region,
which includes South Korea and China. And of
course, the question is when, if and when this
is coming to the United States. Now let's I will
now give you the more optimistic interpretation,
which is the one I'm hoping for. And that would
be. We've seen some other countries get through
the VA variant already. They had their army
crown spike and they had there. It's sometimes
called stealth on Macron or to spike. And
it was a spike, but it was relatively short.
And it again declined quickly. That would be
the hope for the United States. The reason we
might be less optimistic in the United States
is we only have I don't remember now if it's 26
or 28 percent of the population who has had three
doses. And as we learned during the micron spike,
that third dose very, very effective at mitigating
the impact of micron, we've learned that
the two doses are not great when it comes to
Micron. We've also learned that a fourth dose
based on the data from the first micron spike,
the fourth dose dose didn't really seem to do much
to help with Micron. So three, you know it's this
this bowl of porridge is too cold. This bowl,
the port just too hot, whatever. So the the hope
would be that as more people get that third dose,
that we would end up with a battu spike. That is
not that. That bad analysis from the UK Health
Security Agency shows the bay to sub variant of
our micron is about 80 percent more contagious
than Bay one, and Bay one is the original
Micron variant. Cases and hospitalizations
are rising in the UK and in a number of other
countries. So that's why we've said before we
might get to a point where cases don't really
matter if hospitalizations don't go up as well.
Unfortunately, in some of these European
countries, we're seeing not only cases rise,
but also hospitalizations. So we will continue
following it and obviously hoping for the best.